Today, we're taking
a look at three types
of heat resistant gloves,
and seeing how they hold up
against the stove, hot steel,
and a furnace.
[Music]
YouTube user ShishiR
wanted to see
how long it takes for
heat-resistant gloves to burn.
As someone who often
uses and relies
upon heat-resistant gloves,
this question is near
and dear to my heart,
and I thought it was
a great thing to test out.
So that's what
we're going to do.
Here's the basic idea.
Each of our three types of
gloves will be put to the test
in different scenarios to see
just how heat-resistant
they really are.
First up, we have
a pair of oven mitts.
These things say
that they are
silicone coated cloth,
and I think they're supposed
to be rated up to about
500 degrees Fahrenheit,
which is going to be good
for pulling most everything
out of the oven,
but not necessarily some
of the stuff we do here
on this channel.
Standard oven mitts,
about what you've seen before,
pull things out of the oven.
Pretty low dexterity
because all your fingers are
together with just the thumb
off to the side.
Hello.
How are you?
That would make
a decent whale puppet.
Next up, we've got
leather furnace gloves.
These are usually used
for furnace work or for welding.
And so I'm pretty
familiar with these.
We've definitely used
gloves just like this here
on the channel quite a bit.
They worked pretty well, pulling
stuff out of the foundry,
putting stuff into the foundry,
but I have had
some issues with that.
Weirdly, we've had
several pairs of these gloves
where the right index finger
getting the most heat exposure
ended up shrinking over time,
until I could barely fit my hand
into the glove anymore.
Lastly, we have these,
which are supposed to be
barbecue gloves they say.
However, these are rated up
to about 500 degrees Fahrenheit,
these say they're rated up
to about 950 degrees Fahrenheit.
These ones claim
that they are heat resistant
up to 1,450 degrees Fahrenheit.
So these are the highest rated.
and I've never tried
these out before.
They are stretchy,
and they have sort of
silicone pads on the front
to give you some more grip when
you're holding on to things.
They're clearly knit.
Like you can see the texture.
It just looks kind of
like winter gloves texture.
Although, they're
much much thicker.
We're going to test
each of these,
putting our hand on a hot stove,
grabbing a red-hot bar of steel,
and putting our hands
near or inside our foundry.
I am actually putting
myself at risk for this.
I'm going to be
the test subject.
Today, we're going
to start with a stove.
We're going to turn
up the heat, and see
how long I can keep
my hand on the stove,
in the glove before it starts
feeling really uncomfortable.
We're going to let
it get red hot,
and then I am not going
to touch it with my bare hand.
I'm going to touch it
with a mitten hand,
and then two gloves.
Start to get hot.
Let's see where this is
at right now.
Registering at 226.
Now, that is the surface
temperature of the glass.
This thing is using infrared.
It can't see through
the glass surface.
About to hit 500 Fahrenheit.
There it is, 500 Fahrenheit.
At this point, a drop
of water just explodes boiling,
and then we get
some drips moving around
with the Ladenfrost effect.
We just hit 935 Fahrenheit,
which is 500 degrees Celsius.
Seems like the time
to put our hand on it.
Alright, here we go.
About to put my hand
on a hot stove in the oven mitt.
[Music]
Well, that was quick.
When someone says it's
heat resistant up to 450,
maybe 500 Degrees,
you probably shouldn't put it
down on a 950 degrees surface.
That was maybe like
one second, I think?
Did not last very long.
All right.
Well, despite how long
that didn't last,
we're going to progress on
to the next gloves.
Okay, here it goes.
[Music]
That was mostly me reacting
to the smoke I saw coming off,
but it did start burning
one finger over on that side.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just about one second,
and it started getting
too hot down inside.
Everywhere that was actually
pressing hard against the glass,
and my pinky finger was
what was pressing the most,
and that got uncomfortably
hot very quickly.
I am going to try
one more thing,
and that's I'm not going
to press down on the glass.
I'm just going to hold
my hand over the stove.
Smoking quite a bit.
Too hot.
Leather gloves on the stove.
More protection than
the oven mitts,
but not by a lot.
Now, we have
these barbecue gloves,
which in theory, give us
the most heat resistance.
The one thing I want
to test is if it sticks,
because if it melts and sticks,
and I can't pull
my hand away as quickly,
that would be huge problem.
So I'm just gonna test
with one finger over here.
So we've got some burning.
Full-scale test, here it goes.
[Music]
Wow, I'm actually
very impressive at that.
I left my hand on there
for several seconds.
The other gloves
got maybe one second
before they started smoking,
and in one case,
burst into flames.
A lot of smoke on the leather,
a lot of fire on the oven mitts.
This was actually much better.
I pulled my hand off
when it got uncomfortably hot,
but it was only just
barely uncomfortably hot.
The leather went
from nothing, nothing,
nothing, uncomfortably hot,
you've burned yourself.
With this glove,
it didn't actually do that.
It got warmer and warmer,
and I thought,
this is now uncomfortable.
Pulled my hand off,
pulled the glove off,
never got to the point
where I felt like my hand
was actually burning.
I'm quite impressed.
Let's try the next thing.
[Music]
Alright, at this point,
we have a steel bar
that is glowing nicely orange.
We're not just gonna go
and grab right onto
the red part of the bar.
That's going to burn the gloves,
it's going to be a lot
like putting it
on the stove but faster.
I don't want to injure my hands.
So we're going to do
is compare and see
how close we can get,
how far up the bar
toward that red part we can get
without hurting yourself.
So, I'm actually
gonna do a control
with just my bare hands.
I know that the back
of this isn't burning me,
but I'm going to see
how close to the orange part
I can get with my bare hand
before it's uncomfortable.
And then I'm going to go
through the other types
of gloves, and see
how well they protect me.
[Music]
Little more, not
uncomfortable yet.
[Music]
Now, getting-- Oh!
Yep, just about there.
The top half of my hand
is uncomfortably hot.
So we've got these two
weld marks on here.
Just below those,
that's as close
as I could get.
That was burning my hand
uncomfortable to leave it there
for more than a second or two.
Yep, and then anything
higher than that,
it just burns too quick.
[Music]
All right, starting pretty close
to what was the maximum
with my bare hands.
Now this right here was
too hot with my bare hand.
I couldn't handle it.
So far, not really
problem with this glove.
Moving up a little bit more.
Oh, definitely feeling heat now.
Oh, I got smoke coming
off the glove.
Still my hands
actually all right.
My hand was actually doing okay,
even though the mitten
caught on fire,
and now there's a big hole in it
because I think some
of the stitches burned.
So, that's actually
pretty impressive.
The stitches failed,
and it caught on fire,
and my hand was only,
you know warm.
[Music]
Whoo.
Yeah, there we go.
That's just all coming apart,
nice and singed.
No longer good for cookies.
All right, we're
starting right here.
[Music]
I'm feeling nothing,
not even warmth.
Moving up.
My hand is now like an inch
and a half away from the orange.
I see smoke on the glove.
Oh, that got through
because it's done that.
I'm now kind of-- Oh, wow.
I don't know how well
you can see that,
but the whole glove just shrink.
Look at this.
I'm not moving my hand.
It's just contracting
the leather.
[Music]
Well, that was flat a bit ago.
My hand is actually okay.
It's very warm.
It's not burning me.
Starting really close
to the orange part.
[Music]
I felt it,
little spot on my thumb.
Oh, I've got a hole right there.
I'm just gonna go orange part
right on the palm.
That is crazy.
It's just warm.
All right, now it's getting hot.
Oh, it's on fire.
Well, I think we found
the stress point
where that dies out.
Despite that, my hand just
barely got uncomfortably hot,
and that was pressing
the red hot bar of steel
down onto this glove
for several seconds.
I gotta say,
I'm really impressed
with these things.
When they say they
are heat resistant,
they're not kidding around.
Thousand-degree, nice,
got nothing on that.
That was well over
a thousand degrees.
That was probably more
like 1,500 to 1,800 degrees.
But now, I want to see
how these handle
actually protecting my hand
as it goes into the furnace.
So I'm just going to sort
of carve out a little spot.
I'm going to reach in,
and see how they do.
First, we got this Mitten.
This is the one
that got burned on the stove.
At least the seams
are all intact.
So I'm just going
to kind of lower my hand
in protected side down,
see how long this keeps
me feeling safe.
One, two...
It's on fire.
So an oven mitt
that catches on fire.
I gotta say,
although I know
I'm misusing it,
I feel like that's
not a good design choice.
Leather glove.
Let's see how this
protects my hand,
just sort of chilling out
right in the hot spot.
This is already doing way better
than the oven mitt.
Oh, the fingers are contracting.
Oh, hot!
As we saw with the other glove,
when the leather
heats up too much,
it just contracts.
In this case,
the first indication I had
that something was wrong was
that my fingers
are getting squished.
And our fancy barbecue gloves.
Now, this is the one
that I have not melted
any seams open on.
Yeah.
There's the back.
Pretty hot.
Not burning me hot, but...
All right.
That's a-- Oh!
Yep.
There we go.
That was just a little bit
harder to take off of my hand.
However, pretty
impressed with that.
Oven mitts, good for pulling
cookies out of the oven.
Not good for anything else.
Don't touch a hot stove.
Don't put an oven mitt
in a furnace.
Leather gloves.
Definitely better
than the oven mitts.
However, they do still have
a tendency to light on fire,
or at least smoke a lot.
They shrink when
they get too hot,
and they really have a point
where they go from it
doesn't hurt
to "Oh, that's pretty warm-- Ow!"
And just skips over
"it's getting hot,"
and goes right into burning.
These gloves that
are for barbecuing,
or whatever else you're using
them for, I'm actually
quite impressed with.
I would say
the biggest downside is
that it does actually slow
my hands down a little bit
trying to pull out.
This restricted cuff,
while it might be
good for aesthetics
or even functionality
of using the gloves,
I don't like that it's harder
to pull my hands out.
However, these did
an impressive job
of resisting the heat.
There's one more thing I
want to try, the question
that was actually posed to us is
how long does it take
for them to burn.
So we're just gonna
do a quick test,
and drop them down
into the furnace,
and see how long
it actually takes
for them to light on fire.
We're gonna just toss this on,
and see how long it takes.
1, 2, 3, 4...
4 seconds before we started
seeing flames fly off of it.
All right, leather glove.
Can you beat four seconds?
1, 2, 3, 4...
16, 17, 18, 19, 20,
21, 22..
I'm not sure this
is going to light on fire,
because we're already
at like 25 seconds,
and while it's definitely
shrinking and shriveled,
and very hot and smoking,
it hasn't caught on fire.
So how long did it take to burn?
I would say after about six
or seven seconds.
I would have declared
it as burning.
But in terms of getting
it to light on fire,
it's lasted quite well so far.
Okay, leather glove,
will light on fire?
Yes.
How long did it take?
That was a couple of minutes.
It's so deformed,
and it's got like these stubby
little fingers now.
That really shrinks
quite a bit in the heat.
All right, fancy barbecue glove.
How do you do?
Four seconds with the oven mitt,
a couple minutes to actually
get the leather gloves
catch on fire.
Oh, that looks
like it's already on fire.
That was quick.
That's very surprising given how
well it resisted heat before.
That's on fire.
I think it's the silicone
actually caught on fire.
That's interesting.
So the leather glove resists
catching on fire better.
This resists just
general heat better.
ShishiR, thank you
for your comment suggestion.
We've learned some good things
about gloves today.
Guys, that's all for today.
But you know,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box at the top is going
to take you to her last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
If you hit this bomb
here in the middle,
you'll be subscribed
to the channel,
so you never miss a cool video.
Don't forget to ring that bell
so you get the
notifications about it,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.